en sus casi 800 años de existencia la
bahía de westminster ha sido testigo de
hechos históricos pero ninguno como este
el funeral de la reina isabel segunda
que tendrá lugar el lunes será la
operación policial más grande en la
historia del reino unido- últimos toques
de pintura instalaciones para cientos de
cámaras de prensa e incluso edificios
colindantes las calles siguen siendo
accesibles al público pero no por mucho
tiempo los londinenses disfrutan de las
vistas antes que las instalaciones sean
bloqueadas nava harland nunca hemos oído
londres es tan tranquilo es muy quieto
es muy respetuoso pero puedes ver todos
los preparativos que están sucediendo
ahora
no creo que sea algo que hayamos visto
antes y dudo mucho que sea algo que
volvamos a ver al caer la noche continúa
en los ensayos para el desfile militar
con caballos que practican sus pasos
mientras algunos dobles reemplazan a la
familia real la cual encabezará la
procesión el protocolo se ha preparado
durante años aún así la presión aumenta
especialmente por la seguridad por esa
razón hay policías vigilando
constantemente desde los tejados del
palacio de buckingham y patrullas sobre
el río támesis según las autoridades
británicas la alerta de terrorismo es de
nivel 3 por lo cual están decididos a
evitar que londres sufra ataques como el
del puente de westminster en 2017 pero
por ahora la atmósfera es más de emoción
y afecto incluso en las largas colas que
conducen al ataúd de la reina